next question the police
kill about a thousand people a year in
contrast there are about 250
000 medical malpractice deaths per year
and people of color have high medical
mortality
should we start a movement to defund
doctors
yeah um yeah i wonder that 250 000
medical malpractice deaths
um seems high to me um but i'm sure it's
more than a thousand i'm sure it's it's
more than the number of
uh people killed by police every year
yeah you know i have seen some of these
uh
yatrogenic harm numbers and they i don't
remember they're staggeringly they are
staggering which you know i think we
have to be
careful because you don't want the
number to be zero
right because basically you have no
medicine at that point well
and just just it's a it's a harder thing
to say but i've actually heard
um i think i've heard sam harris say
this right like you don't
want uh the number of people killed by
police
to be zero either right right because
that's airing too far
in the other direction well you've
either that's the thing that it's
basically impossible to say right now
but um but for any of these things where
there's you know there's tragedy there's
individual human tragedy reducing that
to zero means that you will create a
whole other kind of tragedy which
doesn't yet exist
um in its in its wake yeah i think the
easy way to see this
is we could reduce highway deaths to
zero easily with current technology
right and they're really two ways to do
it either you prevent all driving
or you set speed limits
so low and so that the requirements for
vehicles so high that nobody could
possibly
injure anybody you know if we're all
driving a tank at two miles an hour
right then you can get highway desks
pretty low
pretty quick yeah sounds like a party it
does not and so the point is we've all
made this decision
right yeah probably you don't go out and
say what is the
safest possible car i could buy right
you say
oh that's a very safe car and new
parents are more likely to veer in that
direction and this is why
we have these like stereotypes about
what the kinds of cars that new parents
buy but
even then even then you are much more
likely to go to consumer reports
and see oh this one gets a five-star
crash rating rather than
the gas economy like the mileage is
terrible and
right right but you know so lots of
people will go with i want a five-star
crash rating but they won't go you know
if
some car that has dismal this or that
uh happens to be safer they often will
not buy it because we all
calculate that okay this risk is
sufficiently low that now some other
parameter is
um more important and you know of course
there is an interaction
if you um buy a car with cruddy mileage
because it just so happens that it is
the top uh
you know the safest car well then that's
going to cost your
family in terms of how much resource it
has based on how much you're spending
and so that will have an interaction you
know potentially the quality of food you
buy or something else so
you know even if you're dealing with
health as your top consideration
it's a complex equation yeah um
but so i mean the point which is um
could be read as a glib
is is a a good one right like
for any of so just to read it again the
police kill about a thousand people a
year
in contrast there are about 250 000
medical malpractice deaths per year
and people of color have higher medical
mortality should we start a movement to
defund doctors
it's it's a perfectly
analogized point pick anything where
there are deaths that that you don't
want to happen
find that there is disproportionate uh
death in some demographic that has been
historically underserved by a system
and argue that that entire system should
be defunded as a result because the only
possible reason which is you know
implicit here
the only possible reason that there
could be disproportionate effects
on an historically uh disadvantaged
group is
modern racism yeah systemic racism ism
whatever
misogyny transphobia father whatever it
is yeah it's a beautiful point
i would like it even just one step
better if it was
abolish rather than defund because
yeah the real point is nobody
nobody including those of us who are
very focused
on yatrogenic harm nobody believes that
medicine
is inherently more harmful than it is
beneficial
right it does lots of harm lots of it
unnecessary
and therefore preventable but you know
the idea that abolishes the next step is
a non-sequitur just as it is with the
[Music]
cops
you